we're gonna do all my life I wanted a
party like a frat star at Alpha Chi
Gamma
Oh fireworks fireworks going on ah the
Charter is revoked you trashed this
place and now I can legally take over we
are the last remaining alphas we're
gonna have a party everybody remembers
how awesome our parties were what
lessons it sucks ass so what's on your
mind [ __ ] this oh yeah I'm so sorry
if you can muster up 15 members then
I'll officially reinstate ax jetsam
possibly like your sister so don't screw
up you're done amazing home sweet home I
think we're back I'm pearl as in we're
gonna recruit the guys nobody knows
about
he has a female a jacket for an
objection actually you're ready to be
ball deep in some sorority who happens
we see great potential in you but with
great power comes great responsibility
not all of us are blessed with religious
life abilities the mom soon didn't see
my first non-internet tit until last
year maintain a level of decency that
will always reflect on the school and a
positive light
then we're gonna do bunch stuff we're
gonna do BUTT STUFF smell that Wow
sometimes you just sound like
Shakespeare
you can thank me later